you have to [__] understand this you
do not hate yourself you do not think
you suck you just got unfortunate that
somebody in your life created that
framework
Sydney what's good
thank you thank you so happy to be here
all right good sit
many people here today in the pre-event
survey said that their biggest issue was
Finding motivation and inspiration what
are your thoughts on this well you can't
be motivated when you don't like it
I got B's and F's my whole life because
I [__] hate in school
like I'm telling you man the world's got
it upside down
the quickest way to buy the things that
people think they want is to like what
they do
but everyone thinks it's the other way
around let me Chase the money then I'll
have it then I'll be happy
you are very wrong
because I know unlimited Miss Universe
[__] billionaires
one of the things you said recently was
that there were two ways to build
something great either you have deep
levels of insecurity that you use as
feel
or a deep level of confidence can you
expand on that
yeah I think the things that when people
look at people accomplishing
wealth or six
commercial success it's just very
obvious that the fuels are very opposite
it's like it It's like Star Wars had it
all figured out
right like
you know the force and the dark side are
actually very close
but in the end good wins and I believe
that I think most people achieve big
things from a heavy driver of deep
insecurity they're gonna [__] show
the world [__] you mom and dad in the
world and they just it just drives them
and I think there's another energy which
is rare
is they just love everything and
everybody and it just drive like the
love drives them and so it's a simple
Game of Love and Hate and the more
extreme you are on those two energies
the more you've got fuel to create
Commercial Success the issue is if you
build your financial and Commercial
Success Through insecurity
Darkness it's not sustainable once you
get there
the reason there are so many people in
the world that have made but then lost
is because that's what happened to them
and so I just feel like a lot of people
get to a mountain that they put on a
pedestal and then they get there and
it's really bad
and so this is why I'm so passionate
about self-esteem and self-awareness and
all the [__] I talk about because
I'm old enough now to have watched a lot
I've lived in a lot of rooms I've been
in all sorts of places from the dirt to
the penthouse and it's just very clear
to me what life's about and how
everybody's interacting and
I just want people to be happier because
it feels nice for you did the confidence
and self-esteem come naturally from
parenting you received or did you build
that over time
I think it was like this is why it's so
fun for me to like talk about things I
do I don't think it has anything to do
with me it was all built I'm the
byproduct of my parents in my
environment
you know when people like garyvee you're
awesome I'm like
cool like when people are like I'm super
detached from garyvee
that what did I do
I didn't have sex that night my parents
did
right
and then my parents made me my parents
groomed me my mom is
an all-time human being
like
to you know the number one challenge for
everybody in this room as a parent is
are you willing to build self-esteem
into your children without it becoming
delusion
how do you make somebody confident
but not entitled
how do you make somebody feel like they
can be anything
while having humility that's some
[__] gangster [__]
and Tamara vaynerchuk did that with ease
with me
then there was also the compounding fact
that we got to leave the Soviet Union we
came to America you know like I was an
80s baby you know I don't know if my mom
was parenting with me today in this new
world where parents are all up in their
[__] kid's [__] would I be the same
person because the other thing that made
me was not Tamara it was the streets of
Edison New Jersey like
I think that who I am today
would be different if I didn't get into
fights in Middle School
right I think one of the biggest
problems in the world is I think kids
should be fighting each other more
I'm not joking
I think we're over coddling our children
so much that like I believe my epic
Trilogy of fights with Odette Weinstock
in Edison New Jersey in the 80s shaped
me like I grew up you know the reason
everyone's talking so much [__]
on social media is when we talked [__]
in the 80s in New Jersey somebody might
punch you in the [__] mouth
so you were conscious of the [__] that
came out of your mouth
now everyone's a [__] keyboard
Warrior
and thinks they're a [__] tough guy
[Music]
on the note of keyboard Warriors how do
you recommend that someone responds
emotionally to those comments let me
ping you a scenario
you wake up and you grab your phone and
you start consuming content
and you see something and you decide to
make somebody feel bad because you leave
a shitty comment on their content
could you imagine a worse existence
simple
like if somebody's [__] on you in
the comments and says you're stupid or
you're ugly or you're missing me and
that don't feel bad for you feel bad for
them
I don't know I deal with it very easily
but you also have to be careful the
biggest reason people struggle with
negative comments
is because they believe the positive
comments
the reason I'm able to deal with so much
negative comments is because when people
say I'm the greatest I don't believe
them either
the reason so many people are vulnerable
is they have selective enjoyment of the
comments when people say you're awesome
you're like yeah
which means when people say you're [__]
and for me I just don't believe it at
all in either direction
I'm not here for the validation or the
tear down I'm here for the process
so the competition in the game of
business is that what you call the
process
yeah I love the game of business I love
sports sports is the best because
there's a score in somebody won
you know like I love that [__]
um it's why I hate eighth place trophies
like you're teaching kids that losing is
bad when it's great
like I love when kids cry when they lose
I'm being dead serious
you show me a nine-year-old who starts
crying the second they've lost I'll show
you a kid that I'm ready to hire on the
[__] spot
people like don't be in sewer support
they [__] care
we're like we're like trying to like
suck out all the good [__]
like I love sore sport
show me a kid that loses and then pushes
the other kid I'm like that kid's got it
don't reprimand them
clap them
um I really believe in some of these
Dynamics I like competition I but if you
love the game like one of the things
that's interesting about loving the game
the way I do you have to love it more
than your own self this all leads to the
thing I spend a lot of time on which is
we are living in the greatest era of
non-accountability of all time
it's the algorithm's fault it's your
parents fault it's the government's
fault when the [__] is it your fault
the single reason I'm happy every day is
I think everything's my fault
I'm being dead serious if I'm unhappy I
can do something about it
you're mad at the government move
d
not really we're in [__] Australia
and so if you really hate what the [__]
is going on leave
like sitting around the table and
[__] on politicians when you're not
even voting is some [__] [__]
for the people that want to get started
in building their reputation or brand
what are some of the steps that they can
take if they're too nervous to even get
in front of the camera you know I think
look some people struggle with the
camera that's okay like maybe you can
write or maybe you can audio
um but if you're going to go in front of
the camera talk about what you know but
you don't need to be an expert
you're the expert of your life
experiences
you can talk about anything
I'd highly recommend talking about stuff
that you're interested in because it
becomes sustainable
a lot of people fail because they talk
about [__] they think money will be in
you know the amount of people that I've
physically watched in the last four
years go from Cannabis experts to nft
experts to real estate experts I mean
these [__] now they're [__] AI
experts I mean like
[__] [__]
the only thing they're experts at is
suck it
and because it's selfish when you put
expert in your name it's almost
immediately an indicator that you want
other people's money
why do you think people sometimes reach
a burnout state
burnout's complicated
um look I
q a I think people burn out because
they're not doing their thing
right like we all burn out when like if
you ask me to hang a picture right now
on a wall I'd be burned out by the time
I got to the Hammer
that's not my thing I don't want to do
that [__]
right like I'm exhausted I can work 19
hours a day I can literally do this in
front of this audience for the next 48
hours straight and not sleep you asked
me to go walk a dog I'll be sleeping
within the first second
I don't want to do that
so I think the reason people burn out is
because they're not doing their thing
normally people are not doing their
thing because they got trapped by the
money
either the chase of it or they're making
and now they're living within
the means of that money and they're
stuck they're Gary I can't quit my job
I'm like you could
if you decided to stop spending the same
amount of money that you spend on
yourself
you could sell your house you could
you could but nobody wants to go
backwards
meanwhile they're mentally backwards
every day
people are not going backwards
financially moving back in with their
parents selling their ship stop they're
not going backwards financially to be
unhappy their whole lives
do you know what [__] up that is
and nobody's talking about this [__] in
a real way
because everything's been commercialized
people literally like unhappy so they
can buy a Louis Vuitton bag which gives
them a boost for about an hour and a
half and then they're back to being
[__] miserable
a big theme that you mentioned in your
book 12 and a half is Candor can you
explain that a little bit you know my
great struggle in the first 40 plus
years of my life was being candorous
which is ironic because on stage I'm a
beast
this has been a great 15 minutes of
candor
one-on-one the more I cared about you
the less I was likely to be candorous
and that really is the true personality
trait that has led to the most
unhappiness and most detriment in my
career and so
yourself what I'm good at I'm marketing
to myself
and I created a concept and a word
called kind
and by looking at Candor as something
that had kindness in it
it's really changed the way I've acted
and so I think for a lot of people in
this room they have a lot of resentment
towards people and they have a lot of
things not working because they haven't
been able to actually tell us the truth
of how they actually feel
this is why couples therapy works this
is you know it gives a framework of
safety to be candorous
is why Candor is very powerful and I
really demonized it because my father is
actually very candorous but the way he
would deliberate was extremely negative
today it's something I'm much better at
and it has had a humongous positive
effect on my life my ability to up my
Candor game I'm still a four or five out
of ten
but going from a one or two out of ten
it's been a big difference and I highly
recommend for the people in this room
who struggle with Candor to really
really try to start practicing it hurts
saying things to people that you really
care about that are negative is just so
foreign to me but it is uh it's been a
huge addition to my life and I'm glad I
have it I'm going to keep on it are
there any tips that you've used to begin
those conversations with staff members
or family members
I don't know if you were scared to swim
or ride a bike or have your first kiss
but like you know it's just one of those
games where you just gotta [__] go
like that's still how Candor is for me
like up to the second where I call an
employee to tell them they're in big
trouble and they may not make it here
like my stomach is like this sucks but
this you know um but you just gotta and
and that's where it's crazy it's
practice it's no different than push-ups
or anything you do like the more
practice you get better at it it's crazy
to me in these last three years how much
easier it is for me to go there I mean
it used to I used to like not sleep
the night before by telling an employee
that they were fired it would kill me
like kill me
it's the hardest part of being a
business owner by far for me in my
career firing people it's the worst
and so
it I don't have that same level anxiety
anymore I'm better at it
um
I also bless you I also think we're
doing a better job as an organization of
giving feedback along the way so they're
not shocked the problem with Candor in a
business environment is if you don't
give it at all you're just stunning
people and I was the worst of the worst
Not only would I not tell you that you
were struggling for the last six months
I was [__] doing the reverse there'd
be people where I'm like this is the
worst employee I've ever had
let's call him Johnny I'm like Johnny
[__] sucks
like I'd be in a meeting with like like
a heart leader and be like Johnny's
[__] trash I'd go to the bathroom and
see Johnny be like Johnny keep up the
great [__] work
you're killing it and then like next
Tuesday I'm like Johnny we gotta let you
go he's like [__] you told me I
was killing Friday I'm like I know I'm
sorry like it was just
[__] I'm happy that Ira is gone
the tough 25 years it was really really
it was it was it was really I like using
Kryptonite because I really am lucky I
do feel like I have super man like
characteristics when it comes to
business and life I'm really really
fortunate [__] am I fortunate but that
[__] that was a [__] Scarlet
Letter and
it is absolutely where all my personal
pain comes in my life professionally and
personally and I'm really glad I'm
building in the other direction and I
think for any of you whatever
personality trait you're struggling with
like you're not tricking anyone
you know I think the big thing that
people need to hear you might be
thinking that you're disguising your
insecurity you might trick the 98 but
you're not tricking the real ones
so stop posturing and start working on
it
you need to really quickly realize that
if you're and by the way most people
sitting here beat themselves up and
don't love themselves but you need to
realize if it's
actually let's have a real moment no
[__] I know this is hard but do this
for me because I'm feeling something on
some real [__] how many people feel in
this room by a show of hands that they
beat themselves up and they're their
toughest critic and they [__] on
themselves raise your hand
now this is very important you have to
hear this
it's not you
you don't [__] in yourself
someone put that in you
you have to understand this
you don't hate yourself you don't think
you suck you're not
The Imposter you're not insecure
somebody taught you that
the second you understand that truth you
can understand that you do love yourself
you start me find it and this is very
important
and you have to [__] understand this
you do not hate yourself you do not
think you suck you just got unfortunate
that somebody in your life created that
framework but before you're pissed at
your mom or your dad
this is very important this is why my
favorite quote from vcon this year which
was [__] your grandparents
is very important
as I'm watching people get emotional in
the crowd
don't get mad at your parents because
someone did that to them
you understand please you I'm telling
you
you don't hate yourself you don't think
you suck you don't think you're [__]
it was put in you and you've got to
start the process of understanding you
do love yourself that somebody else's
judgment on themselves created your
framework of judging yourself and you
can get out of this [__] hole
and then once that happens
once you love yourself
it's [__] game over
when I tell you when you love yourself
everything's good
nothing scary
it's all gravy you're winning good
you're losing good this good that good
I remember when like man when you love
yourself I remember growing up if like a
girl didn't like me back I'm like you
[__] up
what are some social media tactics that
you would recommend right now
Facebook reels
you know if you're not posting on
Facebook reels and you're only posting
on Instagram and or Tick Tock you're
making a huge mistake there's a wide
open space of attention on Facebook
reels LinkedIn most people are not
posting on LinkedIn LinkedIn is acting
like Facebook
did 10 years ago
those two stand out tremendously the
third one is the concept of creating
Frameworks so you can get content
meaning doing a podcast not so the
podcast gets to be super successful but
because you're doing a podcast you're
able to get three or four pieces of
content for your social right a lot of
you know that follow me
I'm not I don't make contests I'm just
like you know Julian's filming right now
and like I speak for the content I
podcast for the content and so putting
yourself in a position I do tea with
garyvee which I'm thinking about
bringing back for the content
foreign